so hello again
hi hello there hi joined again by
joining Yusuf for protein fitness comm
enjoy using journey indeed and we are
today doing our first-ever Q&A episode
this wouldn't be possible without the
valuable contributions from you guys so
I listen to the Hobby how listeners at
home so yeah I posted and so do you guys
on our respective instagrams asking for
people to submit questions and we got
really sensible questions of some
unsensible ones but interesting ones
they were all interesting and we've got
I was being slightly facetious but 60
there any mentions of Johnny's legs
there are actually yes very refreshing I
want you to ask myself the question why
Johnny's like so long cuz I to ask
yourself up yes I see it's very
introspective you know so we're going to
do Q&A today there's a couple that have
been asked what are a couple of
questions that people have requested to
remain anonymous other than that I think
we can just oh can I know you whose
anonymous fine for that but do you ever
say we doubt the usernames
use if you think again if we can
mispronounced these names as well don't
mispronounce it yeah so say you like it
just it just in an Arab accent for every
user name please
is it the same person it is really the
same person who thought they got the
single unique username would you only
exists for one person while syndrome
yeah but I don't know what is in scrub
hunt lizard someone's name it's moving
on its name dot last name moving on the
first question is showing physically
swiftly on do you mind if I dip and dab
or okay
can I straighten your hair no have you
you have straighten can you straighten
your hair you can hey I don't think
you'll be as dramatic is this your hair
look like straight well I mean I used to
write when he used to have an afro I
looked like a goat with a beard I think
I stream I looked a lot like a go over
the beard the picture of you mean hack
but it slips by oh yeah oh yeah there's
photos like straight video Mandy if I
can find it we will put it somewhere I
think put it on top of Chris's face for
the rest of the episode
that's there if you are listening you're
missing out we've got three camera
angles here so I know most of you will
be on iTunes or Spotify or whatever else
but modern wisdom YouTube channel you
can see us in our slightly overheated
glory yeah if you're listening this
probably just at a very very low level
hum which is a fan because otherwise we
would actually die if you would Mele
able to see the glisten as well stand
forever
Johnny is open Ruben 20 kilos so number
30 right okay do you track macros that's
for all of us obviously no not anymore
I do do we discussed this on a live
stream the other day that we we don't
whether it does we graduated from
needing to like years of trucking means
that you build enough momentum to not
need to anymore I also don't track you
can do it by feel it's not fun for me to
do them randomly I mean in order from
top I - I do truck why don't you to try
so I've explained um it's just too much
effort for me however I'm about to start
with Tim from we dominate nutrition okay
and I'm also going to be a warrior
programming as of the next couple of
weeks and there's a part of that I will
be talking knuckles I will be
accountable and if I don't I will get
shouted up of a guy who looks like
Hitler's wet dream yeah oh yeah I think
it is
you aren't naturally obsolete like you
two are really sickly you should try
macros if you want to show you if you
want to get Lee yeah well yes it was an
argument to do it regardless to be
honest well next time I die it
I am absolutely tracking macros if they
don't got a little huh maybe not like
but yeah or if I start doing a 90 day
push of focusing much more of a physique
than yeah like once things start to
stall out the I think we take the
approach of if something is working to
fix it
and the odd in the levels of accuracy
that are necessary to do the problem to
me I Spit problem for me with tracking
macros is I'm not naturally tremendously
good I've had to use the six minute
diary is the only way I've ever being
able to journal with a three minute
commitment in the morning in a three
minute commitment at night naturally I'm
not a facts and figures driven person
and the same way as if you are an
passionate person in a job against
someone who is passionate takes sort of
more motivation to compete for me to be
able to do what other people do
seamlessly some people track their water
intake track
you know everything I struggle with that
summaries lot and say yeah but you find
my food well what's the benefit to
trucking you water intake like I don't
know much easier to just get to Deesa
bottle on your desk and fill out or just
learn learn if you learn the principles
and embed the habits after a while you
don't even need to do them anymore
mmm-hmm so let me up I really thank you
so much okay it's a truck and you do
nutrition what do your daily routines
look like at the moment who's up you
know you're not doing
you said don't read people I said not
only a couple of people who asked me to
be anonymous how am I supposed to know
if they say everyone just Arab accent
Roger that
Jordan Ayers Jordan by the way is
sending me reading lists on almost a
weekly basis over email and they're all
fantastic saying thanks thanks a lot
lady Jordan is it done the same thing
Jordan appreciate it man he's awesome so
I've not seen any of these well link you
it how are you being sent them through
propane your boss your social media
enough yeah Instagram I respond to
people on what do our daily routines
look like bloody hell
um okay I'll be is concise I'll take the
wreaths I'll take the headlines as much
as I can so wake up outside so I'm doing
sunlight exposure now even if it's
raining feel so much good you've read or
grammarking something new no this is
from dr. Greg Potter who may or may not
have been released on the modern wisdom
YouTube channel our Mises is the iTunes
and here in the past
future well yeah you've again we've
broken the 4th wall of the scheduling of
plumbers pushed it I took the yep okay
so like exposure as soon as they give up
coffee porridge water sit down
meditate Journal sorry journal read
meditate non of the while looking at my
phone then get off prep my food if I
need to prep if not I've got a food
prepping company that's doing for me
thank you very much student nutrition
head to the gym trained head to the
office work come home and then either my
evening routine needs optimizing it to
our own worst at the moment and it tends
to be Netflix at the moment chill out
I'm dialing back my double screening of
phone and TV
and if not I'll be at work or I'll be
doing something social or potentially
training twice if I've got in me how are
you guys you sit up train come home
meditate
[Laughter]
my initial reaction okay I'm off to grow
yeah if I like you put a shirt on
nametag on go to hospital totally fine I
stand the rather the hospital for a
while come home work on various projects
and recently it's the bedtime routine
that's been the big thing for me
yeah so just trying to minimize screen
time post 9 p.m. is the biggest part
have it I have wish it and it's not even
fun procrastination stuff it's like
shitty admin that's just low level
stress and keeps the mind momentum going
before you go to sleep so eliminating
that red light
magnesium spray or Zetas may worry using
like nazy was very low back know about
in Iran haha ho anus or but for some
reason I thought whole like the whole
not the bumhole yeah the bump as a whole
I mean that that routine has collapsed
this week is my arm had a big push yeah
it's weird isn't it like your evening
routine so we would say so either the
times that routine collapses and the
self-care routines are the first things
to go even though they show when you are
most needed exactly
hmm it's one of the most stress that you
meditate the least yeah which is exactly
when you need it yeah and then I Johnny
with the day tell us because you're the
one that's gonna be trialing something
from Aubrey Marcus yeah you are then I
hope you having a bone broth I to be
honest I the book annoyed me a lot to
see today by Aubrey Marcus I think it
leads you in thinking there's some
decent suggestions here like the the
hydration thing in the mornings
interesting the light exposures
interesting and then it just all he
knows that you're throwing up in a
bucket after letting another man have
sex of your wife he was like the he
argues the way these running a massive
private company in America is because he
used assertive interns in his office and
I'm sorry I just don't buy something
like that moving on
so my routine is probably so very
similar I do wrong what in the morning
yep I meditate in the morning I try and
read or listen to something in the
morning normally listen inaudible I do
something called the work by Byron Katie
which is it because be massively helpful
I keep trying to lend Chris the book but
he just doesn't want it I journal in an
Evernote file that's got like over 200
entries in that now just some
interesting reading nice well study
that's it I'll say I've tried everything
up trying so actually recently I've been
trying training away during the day
hasn't really just beginning to try to
try training earlier so I did I did
training in the morning for six months
more or less and it is good but the
trouble was just the amount of my yet at
this point and I know it's you start
work later and finish work later I have
this natural kind of disruption to my
day from a work perspective because my
girlfriend gets home to said time like
two
continue working feels wrong so I've got
this like window where I've got to get
our work done and the later I start what
to the Moors are you saying is that if
you go from determine you're working
that's a problem but if your girlfriend
gets home and y'all know home because
you're at the gym so what are we trying
to do recently we had a business coach
probably a year ago and I was talking to
about this I was like I always struggle
to like arrange these pieces at my pace
that it's just kind of I run into the
fewest problems it was just like just
stop work at 3:00 p.m. yeah and I've
told you about this Parkinson's Law it
just means that you just I've done it
two days this week I find it really
really difficult to do like stop do all
those habits start wick finish your 3
p.m. and lo and behold on those days got
more worked up and then go to gym but
you go to the gym at that time and
there's just loads of people at no
traffic busy yeah so I'm still searching
for the best time to Train but the
traffic's the problem whereas like I'm
cycling 200 meters listening to the
audio books on five to be on the traffic
in the gym like the people in the gym oh
is more the problem like getting a
barbell getting space to squadron and
you're training in a gym which is much
more well its massive
but yeah much better facilitate ponies I
reckon yeah I reckon doing it in order
is gonna miss out some of the real good
ones because we're not gonna have time
to go through every alright do you want
me to just use my go in order but then
just skip the [ __ ] ones yeah and then we
can always come back in there what's the
largest animal you could single-handedly
cling film to a lamppost who's oh sorry
Rob ransom recognize that name horse
look who's not
[ __ ] off a horse because what's that
their horses brains are like this big
like they're not going to I think if you
can catch it in it I think what you're
talking what we're talking about here is
how docile is ya know exactly I'm
swaggin imagining it's off the ground oh
well yeah because otherwise you can push
anything up against a tree right okay so
they don't do that to a leopard oh
you're a leopard yeah yes so try and do
that to our say yummy net yeah I say try
and do that to an elephant and it's
gonna break through the cling film
unless you can use like an
industrial-sized roll
elephants yeah like I met one a few
weeks ago it like realized how was it
yeah they're so very nice but they're
just like if one quite clumsiness makes
all the perfume Lotus like our finger
has two dimensional foot
yeah okay um single-handedly cling film
to a lamppost like okay if it can stick
if it can be on the ground
panda under have you ever seen someone
just try and make a panda not roll down
a hill
they're so naughty they would not stay
still at all I think I could lure a
partner into a position there were many
places on that boot because what you'd
have to date you stand with this EP lab
it off for comfort grab it throw the
other bit over throw it round and then
run round catch it yeah it's gonna get
spooked with that any man as far to even
though he pun is a nice bear mm-hmm well
I mean okay
how about this pardon blue what blue
where yeah fine where's it going I think
it's more if it starts to thrush like if
it blue well thrashes espect there's a
thing about like the when it flipped his
tail if you're anywhere near like the
the vibration can kill you under the
water yeah oh my god yeah if it's
flopping around it like a car connects
to a tree and as you with you roll of
the colon playing so there's no alarm
bells
it is a lamppost so what are they doing
next to this tree
well I'm gonna clock you're on a street
with a blue whale which for reference
you know your big bait yeah big street
running four kilometers with inches and
stones this okay so I think I think that
penguin Daphne do penguin yeah yeah yeah
that well the thing is they've got
they're gonna have their own expenses
that a quads and they're just not gonna
be able to like how much power and of
yeah I think you could you could you
could mm-hmm one honey and then hands
and just wrap it yeah yeah cool okay
yeah I like a penguin I think you're a
bit bigger than penguin maybe I think
funniest animal do you kadooks that
would be something like a flamingo
because it would just be it would just
be single head poking up and over yeah
yeah soif because it moves nothing love
it's got very very shadowy as dawn
there's no through it you can talk to
dogs for 60 seconds what do you say
that's not what I said yeah who's it
from as well Andy Stoker and this look
you can talk to DA goes for 60 seconds
what do you say I was up because you
right doc Oh on everything he does and
we give it from each other going home
from each other Andy I would ask why do
you sniff for the dog's bones really and
lick of the dog you've got 60 seconds
okay sees the first thing I can ask 60
so what if they loved one what if it
goes well Chris is quite complex and
then it depends on who which sort of a
dog was feeding I would ask it are you
aware of the concept of I hmm okay well
what would you ask I'd speak to the dog
with psychomotor retardation that we we
had a day with and just saying like it's
okay my my life is worth living
yeah don't we we we mum we went to we
went to look after it a great hands that
was clinically depressed and had
psychomotor retardation and we thought
we were doing something really nice for
it and it turned out that it just didn't
want to live really did it we threw a
ball towards it and it flinched and yeah
I'd like I quite like to ask that dog
what was wrong always got
yeah I'd like to ask out these dog why
it decided to eat half a kilo of raw
cacao which is why I've been reading in
chocolate that kills dogs and would have
been the equivalent of eating 15 kilos
of chocolate and then it had to be taken
to the vet so we make itself sick okay
yes Wow I mean it's to have such it
being poisoned yeah so there's a view
that are directed at yourself so what's
it like being Jai chili de gji leader
has asked yourself what is what's it
like being the most handsome man in the
north-eastern it's tough I think
sometimes I'm happens to just beat
people off with a stick but what do you
mean by beep it's actually not directly
very kind of you but unfortunately the
question wasn't just arrested at me
what was it like what's it like yes fun
but it's not secretive given top tips
for so [ __ ] 3 1:07 has asked top tips
to get massive for the cups doing
Crossfit good question um no not with a
photo of a man holding a log I would say
tips tips for getting massive doing
Crossfit just eat as you feel that you
need to because the output that you're
gonna be doing is so much greater than
you're used to let's say that in a
typical session like a typical
bodybuilding a fitness session your
total reps will be maybe 400 something
like that 100 or 120 okay like cross all
movements across all right three sets of
10 the four movements yeah yeah so yeah
there you go whereas in a lot of
CrossFit chippers which is where you've
got multiple movements you're gonna be
talking like upwards of 300 or 400 so
yeah it's gonna be a lower that your
outputs gonna be high basically you're
gonna be potentially training higher
intensity is more frequently once or
twice a day so just eat as much as you
can if you want to get massive and if
you want to use it upon mass I would eat
as much serenus as possible
I would put serene Malta Malta dextran
in your post-workout shake and I would
have had a spoonful of honey with every
meal last one that's a lie can you read
the very bottom screenshot leaves very
bottom one by DJ slack eh no very much
the one about tinder yeah wish I was in
close proximity so I could match him up
on tinder and the ice creams eyes eyes
eyes eyes that was a screenshot of you
Johnny it was it was indeed wish I was
in close enough proximity so that I can
match up on tinder
now what was oh we didn't put the name
in and what you can do for whoever it
was that asked that question which shall
remain anonymous by tinder gold and you
can actually change your location find
out where Johnny lives it's not if
you're going somewhere like Iceland for
example that you can pre drop yourself
when you go to Iceland the urine or not
orthology
oh that's it there it is Daisy's right
what's next some cracking ones here
where do you see yourself in five years
Johnny don't go for ideal scenario okay
propane's massive I'm massive and loads
of stuff my life's bastard penis oh
that's fine as it is okay I think if
that's scaled at the same rate
you probably mat it scale the same
raters when you have a relatively small
penis of everything else nicely got it
you know like you do really so I'd like
to improve multiple skills physically
more on that in a later episode
Mindi propane great enjoy doing it
wanted to continue grow help more people
personally I'd like to have explored
meditation some self-development a lot
more
want to do you at least warm meditation
retreat see what that's like
well so what can that cars come on use
it like to be a pair of long trousers or
those yeah down to my ankles plus brokes
the like my ass is probably very similar
to yours Johnny so I'm not gonna I'm
gonna pour everyone propane more more
bro paying more brogues any long
trousers I hope one day to be able to
buy a pair of trousers that long travel
my whole legs yeah nice you're gonna be
a doctor a doctor propane oh I'm gonna
be a doctor I mean at the very least you
want to be a doctor because you're
almost a doctor now yeah it's it's funny
because not being 80% doctor but
materially doesn't like mix cigars to
say yeah man there's only one your
hundred percent up today is a polybag
shift spiritually I think more retreats
as well spending three months of total
time on the retreat would be lovely
under retreat under retreats like it's
so dense the five years is it's not that
long though is it to get through humanly
my kitty ups you got to do what be
looking at what's the frequency of that
it's about long Z's a year isn't it so
no sir it's more than one a year maybe
two it me about so it for me at the
moment I'd quite like really to continue
doing what it's doing I think that there
is a bit of a glass ceiling with regards
to club nights and stuff like that and I
think that were kind of close to
saturation Newcastle City Council aren't
grunting any new licenses to licensed
premises and Newcastle so because of
them they only stopped they haven't done
for as long as I can remember so like
literally five years okay they trying to
curb binge drink than just don't ones
they don't want any new not any more
nightlife they're okay with the volume
of nightlife they don't anymore
so we're restricting Newcastle with
regards to work I would like to have
competed in my fan
ideally one but at least competed in my
first CrossFit competition that's a goal
of mine over the next couple of years I
would separate to the open yeah like it
so can we take competing across there
can't play Glacia games or rainy all
trials so the same as you go to an
actual meet go and then I would quite
like modern wisdom YouTube channel too
okay subscribers I think within five
years that's easily doable I've been in
two years it should we do and continue
continue helping people with the podcast
because it's incredibly fulfilling to me
and it's very its new ground forming so
every day that I get to do it's a bit of
an adventure well all of us involved
serving more people and growing more as
people yeah for sure
great where is your favorite place to be
Sophie Larkin Sofia Larkin as a Scott
where is my favorite place to be to be
probably embarrassing me in the gym okay
house has to be home it has to be home
otherwise what are you doing if you're
in a place that you don't like and
there's a separate place that you like
being I'm assuming like you mean city or
exact well I think it's so for me when I
read that question I immediately think
of who's that you put your phone back on
you put your phone off HECO where are
you going
no that's not it moved look as that
stopped it recording is wrong yes one
moment saying we used too much screen
time on something no no is it cool is my
mother
sorry Johnny's mother anyway um what's
nice just read on how would you like to
be different if you weren't on Long
Island Chris I got this question quite a
lot I think this is duplicated a number
of times here was it this on a theory
nice interesting question again it'll
probably be quite unsatisfactory
compared with what do you think I'm
gonna answer so it would be that I would
be in a my exposure would have been
increased or something like that like
you know it's propelled me towards
stardom and stuff like that whereas
quite to the country as we learned on
the love island podcast it was the
beginning of a little bit of a journey
towards virtue because there was a
difference between what I realized I was
pretending to be and publicly was being
and what I was with regards to my own
integrity and stuff like that so yeah I
am I think I would have still arrived at
this point of doing more introspective
work and challenging my own assumptions
and kind of turning over the rocks of
your life for one of a better term and
looking at what's underneath whether
it's sort of good or bad but I don't
think that it would have happened as
quickly so for that I literally can't be
any more grateful for Villa violent
experience because it was a kick of the
Oscar I needed nothing so you were on
that trajectory but it catalyzed yeah
the process it was a real line in the
Sun for you I think wasn't yeah very
much so
thoughts on drug use so I'm trying to
I'm trying to pick from different people
but will do that I don't mind the same
person yes focus on drug use and lifting
as a strong level compared to the
average gym goer from the same person
depends what you define is strong
because some people are like hogs the
average drinker bench 200 kilos time to
get on the gear and some are considered
I think I might be separate questions so
just to maybe allow you to get into each
concept a bit and I'm a strong level so
what are your thoughts compared to the
average anger what are you thoughts of
drug use stories what are you thoughts
if it's in a if it's sanctioned in a
sport then I think as long as you are
not competing in something that is there
has a rule that says he shouldn't take
drugs and you're saying I might make a
drugs yeah
my view is don't cheat in sports rather
than yeah do or don't take your that's a
much better way of putting it yeah I
would agree as well people can do people
can put into their own bodies whatever
they want but yeah you you're gonna have
to bear the consequence of that and the
more niche drugs you put into your body
the fewer endocrinologists are going to
be able to know what's going on here I
like learn about what you're going to do
before you do it do it I'll find someone
who knows yeah because it's a different
language yeah they're just world just go
on some forum find some real scientist
you have no idea who he is and just take
their advice it's one of those things
like you can get you can get advice
about stuff that has less dire
consequences of people and you can go on
like just colloquial local in expert
advice but really biology is one of
those things you can't cheat too much
like I wouldn't I wouldn't be [ __ ]
about with your hormonal system
absolutely absolutely on inside err on
the side of safety
I'm like really think about what you're
doing what you're doing
before we do I think far too many people
people have asked us very basic
questions from this have said like oh I
just started blah blah blah it's like
this decision permanent yeah that really
like you know you're not just sort of
making a decision that might affect the
next couple of months like it might
affect the rest of your life so give it
the respect it's you yeah lifting up a
strong level compare the average in go
you right there probably Worthing 20 I
think its funds they've got we've done
that one on the next special that's what
is the one book article podcast if deef
what's the one one book article podcast
you find yourself returning to the most
by George McGill it's for me it's modern
wisdom line with Chris Williamson I've
been returning to this house too
again and they brought this fan out and
it keeps feeding me caffeinated drink
mine is a it's a Tim Ferriss article and
podcast called productivity advice for
the manic-depressive and crazy like me
then it's like 10 minutes long and it's
basically just something that we talk
about all the time which is like we
everyone focuses on for everyone thinks
that the people that they follow online
are these pictures of efficiency
productivity and everything in the life
is great that's very rarely the case
Aragon of the paragraph but the people
who are getting loads of stuff done in
their life typically are fantastic at
prioritizing just focusing on one thing
at a time so his advice is like pick one
thing to do every day I just do that for
two or three hours as not to as dr. you
and Lawson said on your desk is killing
you
the podcast I did recently multitasking
is for Muppets mm-hmm but it feels like
you're being more productive
yeah like the sensation of time passing
accelerates when you're switching
between tabs and doing these lasted
through this but actually total output
is terrible if you're doing a/b c/d
as opposed to just a a a a exactly
what's and it'd be exactly what PVC
Brown gives us and make it stick on a
recent podcast which may or may not be
publishing this one as well in the past
or the future yeah focus how about you I
also like where this questions come from
this what's the one thing that you find
yourself returning to the most because I
think it's very easy to read an article
like the manic-depressive Tim Ferriss
Autopia oh my god that's such good
advice great and then two weeks later
it's gone you forgotten it and like but
actually that and then you keep
searching for new information and new
stuff be like well I found the answer
the solution is not any more
informations and implementing the good
advice already and so like if you use
Evernote and we'll discuss it some life
hacks like save something down put it
into your shortcuts set daily reminders
for our weekly reminders and just your
topics or what yours I've got there's a
few that I've condensed into a night so
I've made it into a kind of
thing that's kind of an amalgam a bunch
of Tim Ferriss is fantastic like James
clear pretty good I can share my list of
was not the one an article or something
that you've read where he like about a
video that you she's Pacific today how
to big impact on me in anything that I
find like that I put it in do you
pregnant you like to condense and
distill down right yeah like a propane
we are yeah with condenses and
distillers of information and so like
there are we we we do that and so I
suppose if you follow our podcasts it's
very similar to Chris's and like it's
the condensation of all mythos so for me
unsurprisingly John Peterson has
probably had the single in terms of a
thinker the single biggest impact on me
the concept of taking responsibility and
trying to shift the world as much
towards good by being virtuous and
enacting the logos as you can and if it
was a single video it's one that we
mentioned in the relationships 101
podcast which was why were fated to be
lonely by Alain de Botton on the School
of Life and I'll make sure they it's in
the show notes below I'll just search on
youtube six minutes and it completely it
completely flipped my worldview on how
to how to judge the quote it's both a
blessing and a curse to feel everything
so very deeply it just turned into a
blessing for me and the curse the curse
was a byproduct the same way that a
light bulb gives off lights light but it
also gives off heat so yeah ten tips our
financial success bio Tom Crean these
amounts a good one I categorically
deserve that that it was on YouTube I
remember the day was released I was
driving to my job and I listened to it
got out the car and was like I'm
quitting my job
you sound a lot like God Tom I'm Chris
maybe got users whoever commented on
that we're well aware of on time career
though big fans
Alan Watts is it who said Chris sounds
like no no no no the philosopher yeah
there's a bit where he's talking about
decide what you want to do and it's like
what you do if money was no object and
working through that example that's also
fantastic right what's next what do you
think is the best thing you can add to
the world or people around you by spock
fit lario yusuf or what's the best thing
that you can add to the world what can
you what can you give like what is what
are you contributing to the world are
they asking general or what you me
personally like you like that so us
personally it's everything we could get
across on propane like helping people
grow mentally physically spiritually
like being able to do that with the
minimum effective dose in general it
just depends on what you're what you're
calling what the value you cannot think
they're talking about you yeah there we
go
I think just try to leave as many people
as possible in a better place like
trying to have a positive effect on the
world which I do yeah well there's
someone who took that in he that was the
advice that he got from his late
granddad and he said it's like just
anything you touch me in a better state
than when he found it
so whether it's a bathroom or a person
just always add value and I think we
just talked about relationships like I
think in a long-term relationships if
you can do whatever you can to upgrade
the person that you're with and then you
leave them with a legacy that's like
after you've gone they've and you know
you say have friends that want the best
for you yeah I think um for me at the
moment my what feels like a little bit
of a calling is helping people to
understand themselves because our our
minds a can be pretty vicious beasts
sometimes and I think that this channel
is quite swiftly becoming a portal for
advice and things that I wish that I'd
known 10 years ago and by being able to
give that to people remembering that my
job is dealing with people who are
exactly 10 years doing that me pretty
much so I'm practiced in it and now I
have the beginning of a platform to
actually be able to you know there's an
endless 7 billion people that could
potentially tapping at this kind of
advice and yeah expediting people from
avoiding expediting people's capacity to
avoid pitfalls and achieve goals how is
love island asks pizza for clay what's
the [ __ ] puss yeah I think all of the
labaik questions the best thing I assume
is just sort of go what's up to coerce a
podcast Newcastle or Sunderland my dad's
a Macan and I'm from Middlesbrough so
said you castle
Newcastle yeah there you go there's one
about so and the Hunter has asked for
advice on getting a chip in the food
rishi after moving overseas you record a
good pro customers while right yes oh
well yeah I was about getting getting on
better summer getting back into a
routine I don't think of your previous
PBS as the things to shoot for like
reset the standards and just start from
the beginning I think I think focusing
on basics so get up at the same time
every day
mhm learn what your macros target should
be ish learn what the meals are that you
need to cook for those and then deal
with that get yourself to the gym get a
good training split whatever the
methodology is whether it be CrossFit
whether it be strength training whether
it be bodybuilding whether it be yogoro
Zumba or whatever it is make sure that
it's consistent aim to do at least sort
of three to five times a week and enjoy
like if you enjoy your training
methodology everything else will fall
into place because you'll need to eat to
support it you'll need to sleep to
support it
you'll want to perform as best as you
can within that methodology and you'll
want to train more you'll like I trained
two times a day sometimes and I don't it
doesn't feel like it doesn't feel like a
labor to me it feels like a love
something you want to do yeah I think
the currency with success in this
respect is the momentum you create by
being consistent so if you've been doing
something as critical described for six
months you're in such a deep crevice
that you create grease it rude right
falling out of that's actually quite
what to do it's harder to have a week
way you completely mess up you train of
stopping it's great exactly the problem
what you're missing is that to just
fight to get that momentum back learn
you learn the route to the gym yep learn
the where the pots and pans are like all
of the little my new shirt contributes
to making your day an awful lot easier
and another thing that we can't we talk
about a lot is stacking the deck in your
favor so if there's something that you
want to do if you want to go to the gym
make sure that you gym kits folded and
in your bag before you go to bed at
night and then the next morning you just
picked a bag up and it's ready to go
like prep your food if you don't defrost
the chicken the night before you can't
cook it in the morning which means that
you break your diet the next day so
we've got another podcast on night yeah
so make the easy decision make the good
decisions easy and the bad decision is
hard and then if you're if your site if
you're diving and you don't know eat
cookies don't buy cookies don't have
them in the house there you go yeah cool
he would got real hazel James asks he
would you most like to interview oh wow
hazel thank you very much she is a
fantastic romance author from America
and her husband is currently battling
with PTSD and alcoholism but is one year
sober as of a couple of weeks ago so
he's all congratulations lots of love to
you and your husband what do you think
who want to sit down with one person so
my initial know can be one all right
okay I'm gonna say a relative so either
either my dad's dad okay or just someone
in my past like a great great great
grandparent wife is dead or not great
yeah yeah yeah yeah I just think um so
there's a few stories about my dad's dog
where like he escaped from a prisoner of
war camp and stuff like this and
weighing nationalities British alright
well then what was he he was in World
War two in Africa I believe escaped from
a prisoner of war camp and like trekked
over mountain what a psycho story yeah
and I just he diagnosed very young and
we just love to I just think there's
certainly lessons from that
particular thing well I think everyone
defaults to a famous person yeah but
actually interviewing like their mother
sided outside like someone who is
generations before you just
understanding more about it would be
really interesting yeah that's cool
that's a really different answer that's
awesome so I think you hazel hazel James
no but that's a good I didn't expect you
to say that but actually yeah like if we
were to say I'm Tom Creole Tim Ferriss
any of you like they've all been
interviewed hundreds of times and they
know every question you asked like
people have done that yeah so yeah
boring answer again from me but be my
dad now like several years on seeing
what you would have to say that's cool
yeah I think I'll break the trend it
would be nice a soy-based up my
grandmother died when I was three or
four so for me basically I've know a
very very vague recollection of her but
essentially like in terms of interaction
no might repeat not would be nice to
speak to her
I think sitting down with Marcus
Aurelius as long as he was able to speak
English lie about Beatrice would be yeah
like if the opportunity is like Buddha
Jesus you know all of them like Marcus
Aurelius is a military like commander
who had a mindset that's lasted like
2,000 years yeah so it'd be pretty cool
to sit down with him as he's the source
of like stoic thinking isn't it one of
the well you're laughing at just do it
so it just these are great but the
problem with that situation I would feel
like if I was put in front of Jesus or
whatever it would be thinking like
without such asinine question understood
Jesus sound like this like if I'm the
only nurse never that's how the trance
acid person comes like do you like what
do you bench bread
cuz I like bread you know house you'll
be really interesting to see go back to
like the time when all the statues were
created and see if anyone actually was
in as good a shape as the stopped using
one and like they were what would they
do
give you a preliminary extension on
water nothing no I think it's bone broth
broth
bone broth any chance I love it Rhett
reps it reps Jeb's ruptured it says any
chance you fancy being my personal
trainer brackets and I mean that in
every sense of the word personal winky
face
excellent thanks gents this has got to
be either a yes or no I wouldn't qualify
to know your answer
what's the most embarrassing thing
that's ever happened to you kiss her
kiss hug by Jessica Taylor Taylor right
during intercourse with a lady she began
to say the sentence spit on and got to
the M in I thought that she meant me as
in her spit on me at which point like a
loaded gun I unloaded full mouth of
saliva onto her face she quietly wiped
it off and said I met my fingers I
apologized laughed and then continued
that's that's up there really soon
velocity it was you you guys know this
already which is dropping losing 23
grams in a period of about 10 minutes
the full story of thighs on another
podcast no we never recorded it we will
do well do like we do like what like
fail is never won mine yeah like fails
we'll come back and but okay fine we've
got it lost 23 grand trade boats
restarts in how long
losses you lose about six six weeks off
your life oh yeah
it's the prospect of like something
that's being done not being used
yes it is absolutely acceptable my
really Monday lot chilled so this is
what I was an accountant it's early
early in my career like probably the
first two or three weeks the so the way
the day panned out was used to train in
my garage in the morning so I'm in my
garage squatting and really hard set the
only times it happened to me my nose was
just completely popped
it's like blood Trent why that mid rep I
spat the blood all over the garage it's
like you're like pretty intense morning
like you're pretty feeling pretty
fragile get to work walk in very sort of
fabricated office environment very
bright lights like you're like 10
minutes ago I'm bleeding all over the
garage and now I'm here sit down and as
I sat down just heard the entire
gossiped my trouser disrespect and
you're like I'm in this office in T
Valley auditing this company thinking
I've got the entire day to just deal
with this its rise it the way I dealt
with it went all the way at the back of
my bus so you you think this is suited
quad popping up from the probably from
this course I would just walk driving my
jacket on the whole day and wait must
hope for the best
yeah it's not embarrassing but like that
kind of like high social II awkward
nasty that reminds me of her very
similar thing which was some Fran
squatting in the gym and then went to
the bathroom came back finished my
session left and then really is a very
very busy Jim realized that I was
wearing like swimming shorts for some
reason I must I might not had my kit
available and it's one of those flies
that doesn't flap so yeah just flops
open and I had full penis off for I
don't know how long like maybe since I
went to the toilet for an hour
afterwards walking around this is a
story you get put on yeah on the
register that's Reggie Lewis well
suppose you might not know right oh so
there's a question here I'm not gonna
say the person because I think that's
what they mean how do I lose weight and
then in brackets please don't post this
I presume that you mean
please don't say who posted this as
opposed to please don't post this
because if that is
case then the question was completely
the namelessly how do I lose weight
calorie [ __ ] deficit mate listen to
the cat theme for summer podcasts or
just go to propane fitness comm /ko
calculator calculator that's it that's
where to begin um let's see some
quickfire ones what is your favorite
non-alcoholic beverage profit yeah oh
yeah I said I was good
series now to start the thing like
vinter coffee
obviously me coffee yeah no I've just
bought a blender and I've been making
blueberry pineapple and parma violets
smoothie really nice misses him doing
green smoothies it's go be okay
palm violet what is your second favorite
animal don't pee with it that's a dog
okay you can't be dog with it you don't
think you know that we're getting that
we getting asked these questions and no
one's the integrity of our answers for
the most part there's not a whole lot of
pressure on but it feels like this is
all hallows right yeah yeah yeah second
place like any other
yeah but is it how do I know well well I
say it like that
is it even now is it at the moment no
right it's because to say like dog is it
it's such a lame answer that's hot yeah
okay that's me
should we move up right okay okay what's
yours second favorite animal yeah it's a
thorny isn't it yeah oh look there's an
Egyptian zoo that has recently been
rumbled for painting a donkey like a
zebra well variously hoping for the real
entrepreneurs but such an Egyptian thing
to do a trained cutting corners [ __ ]
you know this is that this is a really
good one what do you think are the most
attractive qualities a girl can have
official the officia official Tyra took
it
what do you think is the most attractive
qualities a girl can have so we've just
recently done a podcast on relationships
where I say about women laying down
hurdles for men and for me personally
it's being kept on my toes as soon as I
as soon as you know that you've got a
girl there's a the challenge and the
back-and-forth and the excitement like I
need to be for me to being kept on my
toes sense of humor not taking this
Aussie seriously and being motivated
towards something nice being motivate to
achieve something nice yeah very good
proactivity to the lack of complacency
not resting on your laurels for any of
your existing good qualities and just
making an effort those always pushing
that works always pushing you Wilkes
that's it that is a [ __ ] good
framework for being a girl that you're a
guy actually to be honest um would you
ever doubt the girls and guys yes oh
yeah well they're not taking yourself
seriously it's huge most like if you
have someone who makes you enviable
not to show you not chasing or not being
relying on public opinion not relying on
validation is it like a big part of
those no-go as the enemy obstacles the
way yes right holidays
nothing would you ever date a guy if you
fancied them well yeah if I fancied them
like by definition as opposed to the
other two would you eat would you would
you would you eat guys would you if
would I eat a guy would you ease guy
would you date a guy if you fancied them
because it's gonna be social stigma
there's gonna be a bunch about this I
Center okay so there I think you'd have
to leave your girlfriend then the
question is if I felt like I was gay
would I pursue that Avenue no surely
that is the question no if you find a
guy but I'm not gay
would you date them I think to be like
it's 2018 not like to be able to to be
afraid of pursuing a man that I fancy
the car things nothing very very about
myself it okay so let's reframe the
question okay so you you're in the
relationship you can't yet
you need to kill that you find it
wrapped it and you fancy okay d-day hurt
no so that's why I'm saying I see some
it's a few thing within the current
constraints the only so what I'm the
other one I'm the only one in this see
you doing the single so yeah give me
some dick so you want some day give me
so just that man's day so there's two
questions that side by something
organize you some dick I think we can
cross cross doesn't day my don't you
want one I can hear you I don't want my
let's put this is you inbox just I don't
want multiple dates I'm gonna have one
if there's anyone offer for a dick you
only have one to choose from you need to
have some options I haven't had one and
I feel like opening up with my sampler
start like getting like a whole [ __ ]
hot dog Factory of them yeah if you are
liking like hey you want like an
antipasti platter don't need a try yeah
you have to wonder i want to cocktail
sausage to begin with there's two
questions side by side here would you
ever go back on love island and if you
could do live Ireland again would you um
right now yes I would because I would be
set for life
I know again million followers and that
would allow me to pursue this interest
without diluting it or convoluting it or
doing anything like that it's just a
platform now what about the potential
social emotional fallout wouldn't be any
I'm as robust as I've ever been
right now okay so you've done it once
knew were you were okay
like it was boring at times but so what
is something that had connected you with
a partner at a deeper level SS Park fit
I think going through any kind of
collective tragedy with someone or like
any adversity always brings it closer
together
well great can the contest in might not
but it's it I think you don't know what
quality
someone is until you've been through
thick and thin with them something they
brought you suffer by closer together as
we try to sell it our first ever ebook
online and
I think us going to Iceland brought us
together nutty how is a three gem Dom's
I think the I think all collectively
like we managed to find fun amongst
persistent overwhelming it this is
extreme temperature yeah you said made
me an egg
I had to ski it late at night well
several times um for me it's probably
MDMA like I'm doing ambien a ok if you
with a honest that's the most like
reliable way to engineer ID connections
you mean there's someone isn't it
take MDMA get them to take MDMA sit in a
room and look at them and they were
pretty boundless love yeah this if
you're going to do it without the MDMA
there's lots of the so look at David
data the way of the superior man and his
counterpart exercises there's a lot of
partner exercises where you sit opposite
your partner and look into their eyes
for a long period and you breathe with
them one reads in the other breeds are
and then like a 2-way meditation sort of
and then you say out of 10 how present
you feel with them and they say how
present you a feeling with you and when
it starts to drop you know you say up 4
3 7 8 9 and you just do that for David
data where the superior man and this
partner exerciser be in the book yeah
they're actually fantastic I really want
to try them very grateful that person
I'm with is up for that no just like
that's weird like I'm not doing that
that's cool man
pretty cool man here what is everyone's
short-term training goals what total
regional competition just a physique go
of question marks all from anabolic OD
great one Kabbalah Kody 700 kilo taught
in 105 kilo class at Nationals 2018
weighing 100 kilos or less but you're in
the 105 you know I want to be found 100
years or less at PB Wilkes
nice yep disk herniation rehab tumbling
in the house time goals like get quark
or quarter quark that's the one legged
spinning flip yeah spinning flip yeah
want to caucus we were about
yeah most really [ __ ] cool yes
colonel but yeah at the moment just
hypertrophy what's the thing it's not
like I'd love to deadlift 700 pounds is
there like an all-time pinnacle that
people like gymnastics version the 700
pounds equivalents probably Iron Cross
double cork oh well yeah yeah gymnastics
is yeah yeah Iron Cross like a strength
strength or something like okay I just
mean like in the community what's a bar
720 double back tucks said yeah serve
them in like a 720 like whether the more
spins and then like only a few people on
earth have ever done a triple cork and
then like one guy's done a quadruple but
he's like tiny it's like 55 kilos and
just all in one yeah just run run up I
think he there's a couple of like pre
things and just ya know they're just so
good at delaying the spin until they're
right at the top of it and the rest of
their thing and then they leave the
center of gravity and just get really
tired it's just like why don't you do
loads of ring stuff just not strong
enough at all right which is dude you're
gonna be quite heavy as well again yeah
like one 150 bench and I'm absolutely
piss poor rings it's 50 bench yeah I did
it with you one we know a nickel
yeah [ __ ] so you did record for the so
as a very very brief segue here we went
into a gym in Brunswick Park just above
Gossard's in Newcastle I took Johnny you
sit in there on the board in there with
these kind of like Westside barbell
style long standing like
records like overhead press bench press
squat so on and so forth and you move
through I think all three of the lifts
from powerlifting squat bench and
deadlift for reps and repped
higher one rep maxes than were on there
thank you is defining I think the five
you deadlift dead lifted more than I
think there's part of my session that
day I took the water at max for my
weight class you bench 150 for the first
time smashed the record you had one 135
for me at the moment immediately rehab
back make myself much more robust much
more robust to injury and then yet
within the next couple years I want to
compete at a rx cross the comp do you
ever have the goal of regionals I have
no idea how do you think it's a target
that is it I think shy of me tacking
myself on a team and basically bringing
them down hmm I need it's the beginning
of it's the beginning of a salesman's
career and saying I want to be the CEO
like you just don't know how good you
can be in report and at the moment I
don't know how good I can be so yeah for
me CrossFit comp become competitive
locally and then see where we go from
there what is one thing that if you
could dial it up so like there's a
series of skills and CrossFit if I said
to you Chris I have the mixing table
mixing table I have the series of dials
I can turn up one of those abilities
which of those do you think is such a
weakness in if it was elevated it would
really bring up your skills for me
endurance endurance yeah so that was 10x
yeah like I can I can be sufficiently
strong already because it's my
background mmm
not stronger really than anyone but I'm
in the mix so with that but I like
behind and endurance through actually
10x and your endurance would just mean
like it because it's the foundation the
endurance is the foundation for
everything because if you had the work
capacity the strength would be
irrelevant because top-end strength is
never used in CrossFit except for
actually in the games which will have
been by the time that this is gone but
they across the total is gonna be one of
the comps in that way it's very rare
most the time it's an ascending so I
mean ladder with ring law slipped in
between and the reason that the squat
clean live is hard is because you
fatigue so if your endurance was there
would be fine um here's a is a pretty
cool one when did you first get into
mindfulness and looking after your
mental state and
why it was something that Yusuf said to
me which was that you it was the idea of
having no attachments
having no external attachments was the
path to like no suffering in being their
peace what some Harris says isn't it
that for years and years contemplatives
have used isolation as a route to
discover whether or not happiness can be
found in isolation of external factors
and for most people solitary confinement
is considered the worst punishment in
the world but these people have found
solace in that
yeah it's not right about have i
blundered ah no you're right yeah like
no attachments no aversion this means
that you've got that freedom to mmm
you're not the mercy of anything yeah
like if if you equate it's the idea that
if you have this circuit of desire chase
the desire fulfill the desire happy for
a moment because it might require its
mother fulfill that desire and then a
new desire comes up they repeat that
cycle whereas if you were to
short-circuit the whole process
eliminate the desire which you can do
consciously through repetition then
you've got the quieting of the mind
without having to go through that big
loop and chase the desire and fulfill it
and then you just got from Kim fulfilled
you know the things you said about
feelings but from you retreat
unsatisfactoriness oh so the yeah the
Buddhist approach is everything is a
nature are not and suka I think so
impermanence everything is impermanent
unsatisfactory and non-self in its
qualities and so the sooner that you can
teach your nervous system mass not just
consciously but like at a deep level
then you don't attach to anything and
you can just let experiences flow
through you without having to grasp or
push away so that's everything both good
and bad is temporary
never yeah as long as you know because
so it was it was the reps and that I
just like I may enforce those things for
something like realizing that your
entire life you're going through this
material externally validated and
motivated approach to try and feel happy
saying that's really what everyone's
trying to do at some level and the way
you explained it that you wants to hear
it like the other Kashi it's kind of
pointless it's to have all this time
that's gonna pass regardless yeah and
not at least try and work on the thing
that is the most valuable thing you
think the thing that is actually
perceivable of this form of the
interface between the exterior and I
think one of the ways that we stay in
this hamster wheel is that our mind
convinces ourselves that if we were to
suddenly detach from all desire and
attachment and aversion we'd become this
zombie lock that would just yet but if
anything if you see people that are
frequent meditators they're the most
vibrant and enthusiastic and yeah fully
engaged people because they're able to
just dive in with both feet and not have
to so I did take time that's place
takedown theta mines in the arms down
things so yeah I think I had I had a
young I had a couple of periods of why
naturally I'm quite depressive person I
think my native state is to be on the
depressed side of things so I don't tend
to look at the positives naturally I'm
the same and default State yeah like you
you're Native stay isn't okay sorry
should I say just something happens do
you catastrophizing they have a birth
reversal yeah very very much so and
that's that was reinforced a lot through
work and so the business that I made of
club nights is inherently very um it's
very changeable
and it is at the mercy of market forces
and the whims of customers who are the
most fickle bastards on the planet and
what that leads to is this kind of
low-level anxiety that's constantly
going and it's just eight
yeah I struggled to do it really
reinforce it reinforce thought thought
patterns that were already default for
me and just like through sheer [ __ ]
brute force I think being around you two
makes a really big difference for me
doing the podcasts has been like I say
all the time it's like therapy for me
it's really helpful because I feel like
the three of us have very different
sticking points in you know growth and I
think seeing someone who's like got a
clear channel in one of those other ones
is really useful to you I feel I think
with regards to each other we fill in a
lot of the gaps that all of us have and
there's a one of the rules that we all
of us cite to each other a lot is John
Mason's be friends with people who want
the best for you and what's interesting
with that is be friends of people who
want the best view isn't be friends with
people who tell you what you want to
hear so as a really really good example
johnny was working on some new concept
of propane about one through a couple of
months ago he'd worked on it for quite a
while he sent the video in to me and use
it and my reply to him I knew he'd
worked really hard and I knew that it
was good but my response to him
immediately was yeah mate that's good
but being Frank like it's nowhere near
as good as you could be like I know how
good you can make this content and I
think your response usik was something
similar and usually was just like it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] are you doing yeah you're
not so he's gonna be split the business
on yeah
right and you know you went away and you
I think I don't know whether you knew
that in advance but you went away and
you came back and the next time you did
it you absolutely [ __ ] smash it it
was amazing and I was like that's being
friends with people who want the best
for you the same way is the young child
wants the sweets but the sweets aren't
good for it giving him the vegetables is
what it needs giving me the sweets is
what once but that's not necessarily
what it means and then being friends
with people they want the best for you
it's people who aren't just waiting to
tell you about them and tell me you like
what's happening for them and like yeah
but actually what this morning
exactly exactly but you say you ask for
advice and someone sits and thinks about
it thinks about you and gives you advice
that is relevant for you
their opinion yeah so I think for me it
was having a series of pretty tough
depressive episodes like not being able
to get out of bed just refusing to get
out of bed one of the problems with me
and with work is that because I don't
have a boss
I'm never culpable to anybody and what
that means is that I can always make an
excuse about why I'm lying work it means
that I can either by being truthful I by
lying I can always get out of having to
do things that mean I need to leave the
house so and that to me just it didn't
make me feel good like I didn't feel
proud of myself and I didn't think like
that
is this what my [ __ ] life's turned
out to be like I don't want to leave bed
because of some thought pattern like
nothing's really actually gone wrong in
the grounds to getting scheme of things
recently I sat down with a guy who
elected to chop one of his legs off like
after being hit with five IEDs and
losing his best mate and commander in
Iraq like you know I mean like put it in
context yeah it does but you need the
tools you have to have the tools to be
able to deal with these sort of things
and I think that it was sheer brute
force is the only the thing I keep
coming back to and the reason I say
brute force is I force-fed myself
content which made my life better so
reading and listening to people like
Jordan Peterson Tim Ferriss you know sam
Harris all of these guys who spoke a
language which I understood the school
of life YouTube channel is a huge
influence so that's that's my why and
then you know as we've just said they're
like I think we make those three make or
make each other's lives better like I
genuinely would I'd be [ __ ] like if it
wasn't for the fact that we have each
other privately and publicly as well and
you know we don't like each other off
the hook with things we don't we hold
each other accountable as well
if someone being inconsistent with
things or if someone needs support with
things so it's the best thing that you
can do for someone and it's the same
principle you said that you should do if
you are a woman or a man you know you
know like starting a relationship or
dating someone is to hold them to those
highest
don't settle for anything less for both
of your sakes you really like it yeah
very much so there's a couple of island
e once here so i'll get them through
have you been watching the season of
love island if yes thoughts unscripted
filming from visi on earth serie I
watched the first week and then I was in
America for a bit and then added my
friends left so I haven't got a massive
sample to work with there's been some
accusations thrown around about
scripting because they did a match in
action what's called a much in action in
cinematography is where something will
start off on one side and then they'll
flip to another camera angle and
continue the scene and someone noticed
in one scene two people two separate
couples kissed at the same time and in a
different scene they kissed separately
in the market and listen to the live
Island podcast it goes back to that as I
saying that the dates are much more
heavily produced this is because they
don't have set up camera angles quite
likely that that might even be in the
same camera that wouldn't have been
happening in the same time right guys
we've got that can you sit back down
please we're just gonna get you a kiss
again it's like they asked them to kiss
again and say goodbye it wasn't like it
wasn't some crux of the story it wasn't
that someone was about to reveal that
looked someone and they told that we
shouldn't [ __ ] up I mean unnecessary
work anyway to do that isn't it to
create a plot when you've got people in
there anyway that they're doing stuff
themselves I said this and this is you
know anyone who's concerned about
whether or not love island descripted or
not you can come back to this which is
about as close to safety latches you can
get which is the people that are in
there have not had media training I can
promise you - haven't had media training
you get Stephanie 18 from Bolton and
drop her in the middle of New York and
say right so alex has just told you that
he look to you but we didn't quite get
that can you just do that reaction again
she's gonna have a meltdown she's not
gonna be able to do that she doesn't
have that inner capabilities so just
that the what's that
thingies raise it I can't erase it
Occam's razor the simplest explanation
is often the correct one you know you go
have you found it harder to find someone
that's genuinely in it for you and not
because of love Island so I kind of get
the
similar sort of question a lot and I
think that people are overestimating the
level of Fame that particularly I got
out of my season like the early seasons
of love Ireland two people are not
considered celebrities anymore have been
Frank like after one year lapse outside
of love Ireland no one gives a [ __ ]
anymore like everyone's only concerned
about the most recent ones the only way
that you can still be relevant is if you
do what Chris and Kevin done which is
force yourself down the throats of the
people create something else
yep by continuing to make yourself
relevant I suppose that for a short
period of time given this platform and
it's like there you go do something with
it or it'll it'll expire and if it
expires then could you do a podcast in
regards to tips for the gym if you
haven't already from Sophia Larkin
I'm not sure if you've it I don't know
how long you follow this for Sofia but
there are go back with since there's
podcast listen to the appropriate
podcast there are a hundred and twenty
episodes on the program fitness podcast
and the clue is in the name some of them
are on fitness genuinely the best
resource on fitness that we know of
otherwise we would have created it so
you need where we did so yeah one
another question from M would any advice
on getting back to training after
illness because our stream yeah I've got
a series on this called Project swole
that was directed specifically towards
regaining muscle mass after having
illness but yeah but the same thing same
thing applies like same principles so
watch those series of videos it goes
over how I was admitted to hospital for
seven days in an infection on a
background of a six week just multiple
series if this is sequence of infections
you say I'll just go under propane
fitness calm okay there's a lovely new
live search bar alright so just start
typing projects well and I'll find them
at O what would the URL be it'll be
everything so come forward slash
projects well Amy MIT video guide Dean
will make it appear magically on the
screen some
we have totally missed one screenshot at
the bottom and there's some absolute
Bella's on here what do you need to do
to reduce belly fat from Lottie far as
far as I'm aware there is absolutely no
research which says that you can spot
reduce fat the best analogy that I've
heard is doing crunches to reduce this
is like skipping the corner of a
swimming pool to try and get rid of this
bit of water so it's like that muscle
exactly holidays and for losing fat in
general again go back into hallory
[ __ ] deficit yeah well listen to the
getting lean for summer podcasts just
eat exercise more than you eat in terms
of calorie Kenya manager that you and
Chris are used to super like on you on
tinder where's my chance boo confidence
up that's why they get me wrong
yeah I'm bit using it if you tell you
I'm afraid as I explained on a hacker in
your pocket trying to reduce my
smartphone time which included removing
tinder one piece of life advice from
each of you that you would give to my 17
year old son from Jim Thacker Jim
Thacker good that is a really good
[ __ ] question
good god at 17 years old so join me to
stop yes decide on a three-year goal in
each of the four quadrants of your life
so this is not my framework as is from a
few people that's been adapted but body
being balanced and business so a
business could body your physical goal
whether it's physique or sport or
whatever being spiritual pursuits
whether it's prayer meditation anything
on that introspective in outside
anything introspective self growth
emotional processing balanced time with
your family and friends and business is
maybe your career prospects studies any
of that stuff so just have something in
each of those four quadrants in three
years and then divide that back into one
of the
weekly targets and the daily habits that
I need to do to keep me moving towards
that and by the time you're 21
you'll be an absolute monster bastard
yeah Johnny two things first set some
time aside everyday to read something or
listen to a book because I think it's I
think it's the easiest way to just
expand your thinking improve your
vocabulary preview understand negative
range of topics like I would pick books
in different areas and just accumulate
knowledge because if you gets this
install I have it by the time you're 21
you learn so much that that your friends
won't have second one is try and be
mindful or aware of your ego and
situations and how it can influence what
how you react and what you do is I think
it leads to a lot of like knee-jerk
reactions or what is this muddies the
water and there's a lot of right I think
both of those are fantastic can probably
lead on from what I would have said if
there's someone who's 17 just if it was
me I would focus on being as truthful
and honest as I can and that's with
everybody from my self to the people
around me and the ego thing is is
totally totally true there's this lovely
quote from Eckhart Tolle a weary in the
power of now where he talks about when
you have a conversation with someone and
they are defending a position even
though they know that it's wrong and the
reason that they're so terrified of
admitting that it's wrong is because
that admission is tantamount to
destruction yeah and the removal of the
ego removes your attachment to that
element of you and as soon as you can do
that you could possibly for growth just
goes through the roof instead you've got
this basil digging the heels in because
of the fear of death the fear of what if
that's such a huge thing like allowing
yourself to be wrong and embracing being
wrong and like actually to a degree
desiring being proven to be wrong is
it's great it's a lovely feeling
especially when you 17 and I think
youyou already are gonna be wrong more
than you're gonna be you
yeah but you're also wanting to you're
not stable in your in your character or
anything and so you wants to try and
like get a footing and dig things in
even if it's not correct there's an idea
of if you approach a like a discussion
and open with your opinion you
immediately reduce the amount you could
have learned from our situation by
allowing someone else to give that
unfiltered opinion if you a man like
we're all so eager to be right and
doesn't that comes back to turning
conversations in a tennis matches
doesn't it you wait for someone to
finish so this your turn to hit the ball
if you try if you if you aim to speak
about half as much as you listen I think
that's probably a pretty good rule of
thumb that's why we've got two ears and
one mouth though you don't think do you
remember meeting me at Universal Studios
Renee who asked yes I do was very nice
to meet you're an issue is the one
person in America asked for a photo with
me because the violin season one was on
hulu hulu do you keep in contact with
anyone you were in the villa with from
xox gemma xox yes you've got all of the
guys on what's up and do keep in touch
when ever see anything relevant I
probably speak to John Clark and max the
most max is still doing pretty good I
think you might be moving away actually
John Clark smashing on TOWIE Joshua
cheese shagging Charlotte Crosby so I
play Jordan ring is just being massive
advice for an 18 year old wanting to go
to the games hashtag it's gonna happen
underscore the underscore how are you
underscore [ __ ] get yourself a good
program a warrior program it's fantastic
get so many does he program and get
someone that does nutrition set a
long-term goal that don't aim to go to
the games in two years time aim to be at
the games when you're 23 or 25 it's not
the same now as when rich Froning and
Josh bridges and even like people that
tier right Brook Brook Wells and people
like that it's not the same as it was
when they were the the caliber of people
and Annie Thorisdottir went and did the
games people were still doing kipping
muscle ups as opposed to butterfly
because that was the level of
advancement and there was so many more
it was so much less refined and the
level
competition with solo is like from the
outside looking in it still may look
like a the equipment of a cottage
industry but it is a fully its half a
mill when you went now that's the prize
money this year in the 2018 CrossFit
Games and Matt Fraser will be for the
rest of his like he's just bought a plot
of land that's got eight acres on it and
has like a barn that's about 2 acres
I imagine the prize money is like the
tip of the iceberg for what they get to
the sponsorship and oh yeah where's Luis
and all that so that is the quote from
Tony Robbins it's like everyone
overestimates what they can accomplish
in a year but underestimates what they
can accomplish in a decade mm-hmm so
yeah as he said like aim for it comes
back to what did we serve up being 17
like set yourself a long-term goal break
it down day by day
and get someone and make yourself
externally accountable if you're 18
being Frank like your capacity to have
perspective is almost a rub do oh one
more thing for the 17 as well like
looking back the amount of I think hold
yourself to higher standards than your
immediate peer group yeah so he knows a
[ __ ] idiot because I did my first
degree with maths and business and a lot
of the people aren't agreeing about
absolute waste men and because I was
smashing it in relative terms I thought
oh no a.m. yeah but actually like my
work ethic and my like actual outfit was
so low hanging around it's an older
people yeah and I'll get some people the
three years older than you five years
older than you just get what you can
from them all right fine people you
admire on my I think that's something
contacted listener popular content I
don't feel like that existed when I was
17 definitely not work but like the
number of people you can listen to and
like how is it hours years of content
online from people who are really
impressively mother wisdom are Jeff's
just it if we move on
yep I feel like 18 to 28 to me ages like
absolutely ages so much had happened but
I feel like I'll be 38 before another
time yeah I feel like a blink yeah yeah
isn't that strange
yeah it's worrying was so they say like
speed of time increases as you get older
because you've
the same that's wrong yeah more familiar
experiences I think if you if you can
try and cultivate a growth mindset
though I think that you can slow that
that time difference by an awful lot
there is not Susana hominin who I did a
podcast with recently Gretchen Rubin
talks about trying to bury your life as
much as possible and to slow that down
so taking different routes to work there
are things like that like varying eating
with the left hand like just doing as
much as you can for burial iris is the
the master of that has never traveled
you know what you said about saying so
three-year 90-day goals you look back
over a year you're like wow look at what
I've done across all these parts of my
life then when 10 years go by you can
almost look like this but here's the
problem is it's not the experience
itself because the time doesn't go any
quicker or any slower doesn't remember
itself yeah so you're right it's an
atomic reference point so yes RJ Smith
five one five how do you go about
deciding what career is right for you
and what to do in a job you're in but
don't enjoy if that makes sense I'm a
support worker at 26 I haven't done
sports science at uni got crappy grade
and don't know what the best career path
for myself is so we I mean we've both
had a major change of career path and
sort of used to an extent
it's what would you do if when he was no
object they got they so what would you
do if you didn't have to pay for
anything anymore
and when he was no object what do you
spend your dispossess as long as that
because a lot of people because we I get
asked this quite a bit I imagine you do
to people see that I've left accountancy
to do online fitness what a weird
direction I think some people will ask
them that back say oh yeah but I'm
really the fishing I can't monetize that
like there's yes you can't yeah there's
there's ways to monetize most things and
I think there's the risk that you turn
your hobby or your passion into a career
or into a job and end up hating your
passion birthing if you structure it
right I like art the way I feel about it
is if you are I deeply deeply passionate
about something you will be able to and
this is what I'm what sounds like if you
love doing something you'll be good at
it and if you were really good at it
you'll be able to command a good fee or
a good income from whatever it is that
you do so start with that question so
yeah like and you you may be passionate
you may not and if you don't you're not
blessed with passion in something you
can't force it then be strategic about
it and say what what do I value do I
value time to earn money don't have only
freedom and this will change over the
years
but a lot of people and you know I went
to work in finance Manhasset manager and
a lot of these people who work there
they they were really passionate about
finance plus they really valued money
much more than they valued time and so I
remember getting a message at 8 a.m. UK
time from someone in the New York office
nustar's saying hey can you send me some
slides for this thing on long shots and
I was like isn't it 4 a.m. for you it
she was like yeah I've been in since
9:00 a.m. this morning like that kind of
lifestyle if you value money over and
above all else then yeah perfect I you
know there's my supervisor so I if
anyone doesn't know me I transitioned
into medicine alongside propane from
finance there's one of the best
decisions I've made but the so that my
supervisor at the moment did something
similar and said to me like money is not
so he runs a private private company but
is it is a doctor at the same time I was
like no like if I were to scale my
business nationally what would it do for
my income like it wouldn't really give
me much additional benefit it would only
increase the quality the quality of the
problems that I have and so I don't want
to have to deal with that it's like Oh
additional money at this point isn't
gonna help me so yeah but I think when
you've got whatever you have the least
of you home good for that and then you
think like I'm just gonna go to the top
number four that people are like ah I
want I don't know 10 million pound
business or a billion probably you might
knowing the statistics this ring the
research says that after about fifty
thousand pounds fifty five thousand
pounds happiness does not increase with
money there's so much to see that when
you're earning much less than that
because you think my love that I'm like
there's so much literature around
stealing posted million as a business
just creates problems beyond what most
people are willing to tolerate I think
something that I really like is it that
we're keeping with a strategy like if
something isn't I'm passionate about
this look at what you are better at than
your friendship group like look at what
if what are you what are your friends go
I he's he or she's really good at this
and everyone has something yeah and I
think that's an indicator of he's still
dangerous it takes so much introspective
work to work out what that was so really
good example that I like is what did you
do between the ages of maybe about six
and 14 what were your hobbies that you
did back then there's this great example
the Gretchen Rubin uses where she talks
about the world's best color picker so
this woman chooses selections of colors
that match together from however many
there is for building colors and she
selects the ones that work and it's for
like massive jus looks Vivienne Westwood
and she matches these colors together
and they said to work what are your
professional qualifications in this so
well nothing but when I was about 10
years old I had like the largest Crayola
Crayons set that you can get and I used
to just spend all of my time doing that
and to bring it back to me
when I was a kid I was an absolute
gobshite you wouldn't shut up I used to
listen to audiobooks
what is the 20 years later 20 years
hence what is the manifestation of that
it's talking and listening on a podcast
it's alright they're not weird legally
justice to sort of finish off that the
what would you do if money is no object
is a really really good way to do it
another useful tool to use is to try and
work out a Venn diagram of what you're
good at what you love to do what society
needs of what you can be paid for and if
you can try and find out where all of
those things intersect that's probably
gonna be somewhere close to your calling
now that's not necessarily going to be
the most fulfilling because as is shown
by the Venn diagram enough to sacrifice
some of what you love to do for some of
what you can be paid for and a
other things but you know we work within
these gray areas a lot of the time and
it's great to go dick and balls for one
thing but a lot of the time trying to
find a modicum of balance is probably a
pretty good way to go yeah and the guy
asking this question is a support worker
right now and a lot of people would say
that's an extremely fulfilling role
because you're very hands-on you're very
you're helping people on a one-on-one
basis but if it's not fulfilling you
there's nothing wrong with you there
nothing wrong with the job it's just
that it's not the way that you derive
and a bill toward them I don't value to
people in a certain way so like I think
there's no worse way to spend your life
than do something every day for the
majority of your time that you don't
enjoy doing oh I just like I honestly
think it's the worst decision you can
make I would have been seriously
depressed I probably killed myself
within ten years if I stayed at
Blackrock do it I obviously the forces
would have meant that you would you
changed it yeah yeah change a thing but
if there was if we were in a communist
government and I have to do that out of
the window there's a photo of you just
in keeping with Chris's thing's a photo
of you where you've arranged all your
toys in order yeah and that's just a
thing like it was my son dr. Charles
very competent with websites and
Technology briefed on here how important
is it to stay in the 10 to 15% body fat
range for Hyperloop CBT routes and
ruther water for the shark task recently
and the shares and podcasts and so on
really appreciates it oh I remember
seeing you in biker by God roar like a
DW fitness and think let's get the loot
you for that [ __ ] music usage clothes
yeah not important for gaining muscle at
easier like so yeah there are the
physiological metrics for saying that if
you know you you're hormonal profile
goes out of whack if you're too much
about 15% because fat and adipocytes are
a endocrine organ in themselves they
produce estrogen and so if you have too
much fat on your body you're going to be
producing more estrogen
that's not conducive to muscle gain but
the other thing is that it's just a
waste of time gaining too much fast and
having to then spend six or eight months
coming back the simplest solution would
be eat a surplus
this is moderate enough so that you know
you don't stray above that no point five
percent a no point five percent body
weight per week loss and if you gainer
your point five percent a month or a few
bends in the wild I mean I imagine
undies asking this out of interests kiss
last time I saw you pretty lean on the
flip side of that though you know trying
to maintain eight or nine percent whilst
getting muscle as well like yeah trying
to stay too lean obviously you gonna be
playing it out with such fine caloric
discrepancies it's gonna be a [ __ ]
nightmare like give yourself allow
yourself to relinquish one thing that no
one really ever talks about when they're
talking about training and diet in terms
of like a typical bulk cut cycle is that
willpower is a finite resource
everyone just treats bodybuilders and
fitness models and people that go at the
gym like that just like a [ __ ] robot
that's got inputs and outputs it's like
no like if you've been in a moderately
restricted diet for eight months
keeping Mesa trying to grow at 9% or 8%
and then you have to cut from there like
where's the [ __ ] year how are you
give me a lost the will to live
absolutely and I should say as well like
maybe that's where the question is
coming from is staying below that range
and one thing you know but yeah being
seven six percent like you know you you
have the opposite of me I'm androgens
start to drop and so that's also not
conducive to muscle gain so to a degree
ten to fifteen percent is it it's a
sweet spot in like ten ten to twelve
percent as far as anyone else is
concerned looking at you on a beach
you're gonna be shredded
ya know that guy's a bodybuilder he's
big and lean like the oh absolutely
absolutely you'll have a little bit of
vascularity
only you have you be bigger from the
intramuscular fat as well so the only
time that the only person that ever
cares whether you're seven percent or
nine percent is you by even your partner
and like I wouldn't say even bother
worrying about what if a percentage
I know it's under the Sofia frame for
the question but like it's so difficult
to say how my 10% along with some 30
percent seventy percent so I would get
the model we use with everyone work with
his get to the point where you are as
happy objectively as you can possibly be
with how mean you are
you don't mind adding a bit of calories
try to retain visually as that that
means as much as possible try to keep
your body weight as stable as possible
allowing slightly increase and focus on
adding weight to the bar or doing more
total work overtime and naturally by
virtue of that you will be adding muscle
mass at the max of a physiological rate
and just set calories to be permissive
to muscle knots not by 5% to 1% per
month is it but most getting yeah most
but there is a video on this that
related it's a grid and it relate your
matrix and it relates to how many years
of training you've had and how much
muscle gain that equates to as far as in
transmogrify um
DJ slack e85 first one
when's the Leon Scott podcast coming out
I have got a reminder set for about four
days time to give him a message for
those people who don't know Leon Scott
is a pretty well-known Instagram model
and I going to agree to come on but he's
got a crazy busy shoot schedule so I
haven't been able to getting yet I
promise I will he's only from middle
school she's just down the road and but
somebody was like 150 K on Instagram and
he just like Harold London which he may
have heard of and chain and able and
like he does big dick campaigns huge big
dick social-media influencer campaigns
but he's the guy that suggested that we
go to the Kadampa compassion center and
do Buddhist meditation so he was a guide
inside yeah you've won inspired me to go
there whoever this guy is we're talking
earlier on about being an enigma and
having multi facets in your personality
this guy is like completely out of he's
an outlier right I know it's gonna be
super super interesting I have no idea
literally have no idea what I'm gonna
hit when I sit down with him I'm never
heard him speak
Wow oh no it doesn't do like recorded
voice he also plays professional
football the Darlington Football Club
he's got like this like super fit
girlfriend and he's always in Bali and
doing
you only thought shoot and then he'll be
training and then maybe he's released a
like ebooks and also stuff either
interesting [ __ ] guy so - Chris can
you describe your transition from
training the typical weight training
split to the way you do now in terms of
what you notice in your physique changes
and how your diet has changed you look a
lot bigger than your love Island shape
yet still lean Krista podcast Chris fit
podcast yes so problem problem fitness
and such Chris fit that satisfied you've
got like orange to our discussion on
exactly that's available on youtube or
on itunes got all the robotic systems
you share just search approach Google
program Fitness Chris fit and you will
find it you have Ireland fat loss Chris
training yeah we even discuss who the
helicopters oh yeah do so the first
podcast we ever did with you yeah
there's the first one so the most
interesting thing on that watch Chris's
podcast presence that's the most
impressive transformation yeah you're
probably right
okay I've changed my capacity on the
podcast more than my physique I think um
to try and distill that down doing
Crossfit means such training from that
to how I am now it just being CrossFit
like I wish that I could say it was
something else I wish there was some
secret sauce that some solution I've
added in and it's not it's just being
CrossFit and I think again we go back to
blunt-force trauma like it's an awful
lot of volume very frequently I'm
training a lot more frequently than they
used to the reason for that is because I
like the way that I train what that
distills down to is choose a training
methodology which you enjoy if you enjoy
it you will train more if you train more
you will elicit gains more quickly than
you would have done if you weren't
there's something called MRV which is
maximum recoverable volume and for an
awful lot of people that go to the gym
normally i think that miles below that
the number of people that over train
unless they're in a [ __ ] heavy
calorie deficit so worried about
overtraining on there the folks that
just squats this weekend were doing
[ __ ] like I know in your mind or
limit your overtraining way before you
can even touch over train for like 99
percent population train more it's Jenna
I've not seen someone lift as much
volume and and just have their like the
capacity just hit his head off a warm
yeah so much as Johnny
I've been I think I'd be pretty I think
you'd bring hell slaughtering cup either
at a time where I had to I passed out on
the sofa while watching so I got in from
the gym lay down and just fell asleep
and woke up several hours later feeling
terrible shakes and shivers but I still
don't think I was ever betrayed this is
I just wanna see did like a hard set of
curls doesn't mean yeah Pro fit fitness
lock on /or just appropriate fitness
icon
MRV there's an article in it by the guy
you acquire a concept Wow mike is
yourself that is big dick so in terms of
diet for maybe the last 18 months I
because I was training more it allowed
me to eat more whether you believe in G
flux theory or not I'm not really too
sure but I was eating more I was
training more like it doesn't take a
genius to work out what's gonna happen
like the kind of physique as well that I
consider to be aesthetically pleasing
has changed an awful lot from like the
tiny waist massive shoulders
underdeveloped like lower back zero
glutes kind of fitness model thing to
now for me a functional physique is much
more economic [ __ ] for I like thick
in the midsection you know look at
someone like is a good example if you
don't follow CrossFit Google or
Instagram Noah ohlsen Oh H L Sen or
Olson or Brent for Kowski for someone
who's like big and tall and lean he's
like six for walks around at seven
percent body fat and eats six thousand
yeah
6,000 to 7,000 calories a day 600 grams
of carbs that's what an peeled out of
his mind
this is something I'd like to ask you a
separate relation to this has CrossFit
changed what you find attractive in a
woman
absolutely so again because I have no
idea when this one's going to get
published I don't know if this is in the
future or in the past at some point I
will do a podcast with Sony Webster from
today will be one week's time wait to
record it make things so much worse it
is
so it's seven days from now but that
might be 14 days in the past all the
future for you depending on the posting
schedule yeah so um and me and Sonny
have this discussion an awful lot one of
the things that we're going to bring up
on that is going to be that there is a
for both men and women there are massive
advantages and disadvantages of finding
other people that do CrossFit in
strength sports attractive one of the
ones for men is that you are essentially
forced to have sex from a deficit reason
being that if you are doing a girl from
behind who is particularly well
developed in the gluteal area that
essentially your hips are pushed further
away go from the point of entry which is
sex from a deficit and I really don't
care how big your piece is my garage
it's Ramadan is starting I'm doing
deadlifts starting on a plate a reduced
range of motion or increased reduced
well you've got really increased range
of Miraj of motion theoretically but
reduced reduced actual so the Devin it's
like it's like putting a stake venturing
it's like benching the plates and
benching with a from her so there's a
there's a fixed distance internally
fixed distance right there is a package
externally preventing you have taken the
funding from yeah okay yeah it's not yet
board press this one it is it's from a
deficit interview saying that the the
gluten mass and your anterior thigh mass
is increasing on your motion increasing
the total range of motion that you are
required is doing around you know what
it is something tells me increase the
range which is what it's doing but the
actual powers is decreasing the rate
ministration ring though it's decreasing
the penetration but increasing the range
then you have to perform so is
increasing your hip hip movement yeah
which is going get back to the fast okay
and here's its twofold okay the first
one is I don't care how big your pieces
you cannot afford to lose an inch to two
inches off length like no one cut
doesn't matter how well um you I like
that question the men's health one the
an inch of your penis or an interview
it's game internally penis gained six
inches of height off 20 pounds of muscle
15 pounds of muscle 50 pounds of muscle
muscle you if you would if you were six
inches tall you'd be foot yeah I'm 50
pounds of muscle skin so that's it
that's the first part right and then on
the flip side as a woman who's in
strength sports you know if you're
really really pushing at it it is
inevitable that your range of motion is
going to be reduced muscle mass is tends
to be pretty country to range of motion
and I don't really care how strong you
are but as a woman if your knees can no
longer touch your shoulders you've
sacrificed too much like yes you're
strong but at what cost
[Music]
because both you and I have lost out
from that so yeah the combination of the
lack of range of causes yeah wait you've
got you've got started front from front
and back you've got reduced like
penetrable distance doesn't matter where
you put them fine they're not see is
there an advantage to you getting
pancake and splits absolutely they go
what as a man or as a woman I said what
both but for you is a month for me as a
man not really because if it doesn't it
doesn't really matter what I do so I
found my box pleasant I doctor my
abduction is his scoop underneath me has
been very helpful
how have you withdrawn what Johnny
because you deadlift Summa someone's
back and notice the difference in their
my leg rawat for me brings me back to
normal rather than puts me into super
normal
like I think my flexibility is probably
pretty poor in the strength world better
than like your average person but like
if you comparing yourself to someone
who's like struggling to hold themselves
in position for more than ten seconds or
you know gets out of breath very quickly
then what you do right now
he's gonna take regular
I mean regular breaks in regular sips of
water don't push yourself too hard it's
like it's it's legitimately a problem
like we joke but there are people who
turn up to IVF clinics and the advice is
just lose some weight because
mechanically you know achieving it yeah
like I said that dead lifting on 2 or 3
20 20 kilo like the bar is actually
better than lower than like they can
really chassis LaRoque rogue than the
devil ago yeah that's heavy um right I
think we've pretty much completed if
this loads left over but that's an hour
and 45 and completed podcasting we
really did today it's got dark
thundering yeah we have to start again
and high difficulty something that
corset either you get god mode and you
get new outfits and it's left left RB lb
left left right triangle square thanks
menu stuff that will be coming up bloody
hell well I have no idea of the
production schedule but I know that I'm
going to get Alex from cosmic skeptic
who is a really interesting bastard I'm
going to have sunny Webster coming up
pretty soon Sony will be talking about
doping and PDUs in sports which as a
especially recently the weather the
Emily Abbott from CrossFit and a bunch
of other CrossFit athletes have been
popped we're running that suni is when
able to weight lift competitively for
four years because of exactly the same
thing so that's gonna be really
interesting as a CrossFit
no no he's just he's traveling the world
goes to give us weightlifting seminars
and how's the Tron guy yeah
strong guy Tim Briggs is going to be on
talking about eating for performance
Paul warrior Jordan and Tim I'll be back
doing what they do and we have got life
fails life hacks 105 and 106 to go
through an honesty honesty
you've got relationships one or two
we've got the single one we've got
running your own business we have got so
much stuff coming up all that I need you
strength as well but you really want to
do all that I really need to do if you
after after one hour and 48 minutes if
you are still listening a couple of
things that won't you do first one is
head to youtube.com slash modernism
podcast press subscribe the second one
is to tweet at propane fitness saying
please do another podcast because they
don't like notifications then if you
keep on doing it Illinois them into
coming around to my house I will get
certifications like you've turned them
off um yeah seriously no idea and I'm
gonna know it's gonna die job that but
she'll pass that down towards your
graveyard as far as I'm concerned one
this point I do too it tweets the end of
my Instagram because that will come
through anyway thanks a lot Johnny worse
he's right okay bye
[Music]
you